Have you seen the news lately?
It sucks.
Today’s media landscape gives people new
ways to hear only the things they want to
hear.
When confronted with ideas that challenge
their beliefs, many react with outrage, censorship
– and recently, cries of “fake news.”
This trend may seem to have popped out of
nowhere, but this was actually predicted a
long time ago in a book you’ve probably
read: Ray Bradbury’s Fahrenheit 451.
In case you slept through middle school English,
the book depicts a dark future where ‘firemen’
have graduated from saving cats to torching
books in an attempt to silence any troubling
ideas.
Fahrenheit is usually interpreted as an attack
on government censorship—especially since
Bradbury wrote the book in the midst of McCarthy’s
War on Communism.
But there’s actually someone else Bradbury
blames for the dystopia his characters live
in: YOU!
Well not only you, but all of us.
See, in the book, the main character is informed
that it was the PUBLIC that censored themselves.
It all started with the advent of mass media.
Technology advanced to such a degree that
people struggled to keep up.
Information rushed in from every direction,
overwhelming the population.
To quell their anxiety, people focused on
smaller pieces of information.
Beatty, captain of the firefighters, describes
this change – how media’s been reduced
from cumbersome novels to “the gag, the
snap ending”.
“One column, two sentences, a headline!
Then mid-air, all vanishes...
Just like that, we consume and forget and
consume again.
Rinse, wash, repeat.
The mind drinks less and less”
Soon, people became addicts, conditioned to
feel pleasure from frivolous content.
Anything thought-provoking became downright
painful.
As a result, people censored themselves from
any challenging ideas.
They sought to be pacified, numbed, and validated
– soundbites, factoids, and vapid drama
blaring out any troubling ideas.
Blaring out reality.
We see similar patterns with the rise of social
networking and the “Feed”- News story
after news story that generates as you scroll
– video after video, meme after meme directly
fed and programmed specifically to your liking—just
as long as you continue scrolling.
In Fahrenheit, the media concluded that it
could attract the biggest audience by ridding
itself of anything controversial, effectively
ceding control of its content to outrage.
Our media-saturated society is an extension
of Bradbury’s vision: with so many different
channels, streaming services and websites,
media has fragmented -- each appealing to
their own individual audiences.
Fox News for Conservatives, MSNBC for liberals,
and YouTube for flat-earthers.
Yet each of these media outlets must pander
to their audience – which is why Fox News
can’t piss off mainstream republicans, evangelicals,
and NRA members and MSNBC can’t piss off
mainstream democrats, progressives, and gun-control
advocates.
The result is isolated bubbles that become
harder and harder to burst.
It’s like Beatty said – offend as few
as possible.
The truth is secondary to comfort.
And once someone finds their bubble, they’ll
label anything that challenges their ideas
as “fake news.”
Both in the book and in real life, people
protect themselves from any thing that confounds
or upsets.
They just want to continue watching and scrolling
and watching and scrolling and watching and
scrolling…
So what happens next?
In Fahrenheit -- it’s here that the government
steps in, encouraging everyone to stay in
the bubble and torch any stragglers - sometimes
literally.
Are we destined for a similar fate?
Or will the champions of free thought save us all?